alors mon premier choix d'orientation
combiner deux choses absolument évidente
pour moi
à 17 ans un goût affirmé depuis toujours
pour la littérature et l'écriture est un
amour secret pour gauthier 18 ans poète
rebelle dont les interventions en cours
de philo me transporter littéralement
mon bac obtenu je m'inscrivais donc en
fac de lettres avec gauthier pour
continuer d'étudier ma matière préférée
avec celui qui m'a inspiré ce temps je
n'ai jamais revu gauthier parmi ces
milliers d'étudiants et trois mois après
la rentrée et j'ai abandonné la fac de
lettres pour des tas de bonnes et
mauvaises raisons c'était ma première
tentative d'orientation est loin d'être
la dernière
vous l'aurez peut-être compris ce soir
je voudrais vous parler d'orientation
professionnelle et de cette période que
nous les adultes de plus de 30 ans avant
tous déjà vécu la transition entre un
étudiant et un professionnel
il faut que je vous précise aussi que
mon quatrième choix d'orientation mène
aujourd'hui accompagnés des élèves
ingénieurs dans cette fameuse période
que je considère personnellement comme
magique mais qu'eux mêmes et leurs
proches auraient plutôt tendance à
considérer comme complexe voire
difficile à vivre
alors pour essayer de mieux les
comprendre
je les ai imaginé comme des jeunes en
transit dans un aéroport international
toutes les destinations du monde s'offre
à eux
mais laquelle choisir
et surtout laquelle me conviendrait
plutôt qu'une autre
alors c'est vrai qu'on repère assez vite
parmi tous ces jeunes en transit ceux
qui sont pressés de partir leur
destination et choisi leur itinéraire
presque terminé et ils ont surtout
impatient pour eux être un transit
c'est juste une période d'attentes parce
que leur transition est déjà quasi
achevée on voit arriver en plus grand
nombre
ceux qui sont pressés mais surtout
stressé de devoir partir envahi par des
questions qui en appelle bien d'autres
une pression de devoir se transformer
mais pour un milieu totalement inconnu
ils sont surtout remplie de doutes et à
la recherche d'une confiance en eux
assez malmené
est ce que je vais faire le bon choix
est ce que ce pays va me plaire
est-ce que je vais m'y adapter est-ce
que je vais m'adapter à la langue à la
culture
et si je me trompe qu'est-ce qui se
passe beaucoup de questions et peu de
réponses
et puis j'ai découvert dans les méandres
de cette magnifique aéroports qu'un
groupe s'était confortablement installés
dans cette zone
merveilleuse qui est le duty free on
profite un peu de tout sans trop
d'efforts leur objectif ne pas choisir
ou plutôt si choisir de rester encore
dans l'insouciance de leur enfance pas
si lointaine préserver leur bulle de
réalité virtuelle être avatar dans un
jeu où tout le monde pourra gagner ce
envoyer des photos pour rien des textos
pour tous et surtout ne pas se laisser
envahir par la réalité extérieure
profitez aussi des déjà des adultes avec
des droits étendus coucher avec
n'importe qui n'importe quand se coucher
très tôt se lever très tard boire
beaucoup partout pour s'oublier
peut-être ne pas se laisser envahir par
cette espèce de vide intérieur
deviens qui tu es deviens qui tu es
injonction facile quand on sait qui on
est ou qui on voudrait être mais pas si
simple quand tant de chemins sont
possibles mais alors quand on ne sait
pas qui on est quand on n'a jamais
vraiment réfléchi à qui on voudrait être
ni ce qu'on aime faire
comment choisir une destination et là
c'est vraiment confortable de rester en
transit
c'est là où moi je pourrais sortir mon
catalogue de conseils aux voyageurs
figurant dans les meilleurs guides
validé par tous les experts et par de
vrais avis de vrais utilisateurs et vous
rappelez ces quelques vérités aux et
faites vous confiance
n'ayez pas peur de vous tromper résister
à la pression sociale
prenez votre temps et négocier un virage
à la fois quant à ce que j'ai appris de
mes propres choix d'orientation et ce
qui semble avoir guidé mes décisions
jusqu'ici c'est d'abord l'amour de soi
mais aussi l'amour de l'autre avec un
grand a
au sens large parce que j'ai toujours
essayé de faire ce qui me plaisait ce
que j'aimais faire
et lorsque je me suis aussi posé la
question de ce que je voulais être pour
les autres
ma place à leurs côtés alors cette
première transition vécue par les jeunes
elle est bien sûr un changement
identitaire qui impose de 2,2 savoir qui
on est et de trouver une nouvelle place
dans cette société
parce que juste jusque là cette place
elle s'est un peu imposée d'elle même
on est fils de on est fille de 2 ans née
frère ou un et soeurs et voilà qu'ils
font à définir une autre et comment les
accompagner dans cette construction
d'une nouvelle identité
ce serait trop facile de continuer à
leur donner des tapes conseil en mode
descendants voire même condescendant qui
sommes nous face à leur transition
nous sommes des adultes qui avons un peu
plus vécue et je voudrais m'adresser ici
à ceux qui leur sont plus proches leurs
parents mais aussi à ceux qui ont pour
mission de les accompagner dans cette
période de formation les enseignants et
conseillers d'orientation et je voudrais
vous proposer trois points de vigilance
dans cette posture d'accompagnateurs
déjà commençons par lutter contre cet
effet projecteurs vous savez ce besoin
assez irrépressible et incontrôlable de
projeter une part de nous dans leur
futur avec ce genre de petite phrase moi
qui ai pas eu l'occasion de faire des
grandes études j'aimerais bien que toi
mon fils tu fasses des grandes études
mois à ton âge j'avais déjà choisi et
j'assume et ma famille moi j'ai pas eu
le choix bon je m'en sors pas si mal moi
je pense que vous devriez trouver quel
est votre passion bref vous l'aurez
compris tout ce que vous êtes peut
entrer en résonance avec la réflexion
d'un jeune sur son avenir mais ne
devrait pas interférer dans votre
discours pas plus que l'école au sens
institutionnel ne devrait avoir comme
seul indicateur le salaire à la sortie
ou où le taux de placement
nous sommes persuadés de vouloir le
meilleur pour nos enfants pour nos
élèves pour cette jeune génération
mais sont ils au moins d'accord avec
notre définition du meilleur ce cas par
an un proche peut vraiment apporter à un
jeune en transit vers sa nouvelle
identité c'est la connaissance de ce
qu'il a été aidé ce qu'il est en
acceptant de pratiquer le vrai jeu du
miroir lui renvoyer une image objective
de ses principaux traits de caractère de
ces grandes tendances de comportement
depuis son enfance mais tout cela sans
jugement en évitant de projeter ses
craintes et ses espoirs se contenter de
n'être qu'un reflet bienveillant et
sincère l'aider à définir les contours
de ce qu'ils aiment faire et c'est
peut-être plus simple pour certains
l'aider à trouver le rôle qui voudrait
occuper dans cette société
alors ce jeu de miroirs pourrait aussi
être pratiqué par quelqu'un qui n'a pas
de vécu avec ce jeune avec une approche
qui est différente plutôt basé sur des
tests de personnalité et qui permet de
restituer une photo mais une photo
instantanée
elle sera par choix déontologique de
toute façon neutre et bienveillante mais
je pense que nous pouvons aller encore
un peu plus loin et accepté de pratiquer
le jeu du miroir inversé les jeunes que
nous accompagnons devienne notre propre
miroir et nous renvoie à notre image et
à votre avis qu'est ce qu'elle leur
inspire nous qui cherchons à leur donner
des conseils
nous qui leur demandons de grandir de se
conformer à nos attentes à celle de
l'entreprise
comment sommes-nous heureux quel sens
donnons nous à notre existence qu'elle
voit avons nous choisi
si nous nous contentions d'être des
personnes inspirante vrai dans nos
relations
impliqué dans nos activités libres dans
nos pensées humble face à notre maîtrise
du monde et s'il pouvait aussi nous
renvoyer à notre propre image de ce que
nous étions lors de notre première
transition les accompagner vers le futur
professionnel ne peut plus limité alors
transmettre les codes du monde que nous
avons construit car aujourd'hui que leur
proposant nous un emploi garanti à vie
trente ans de mariage
une vie de famille stable la sécurité
publique
un équilibre écologique la suprématie de
l'homme sur le progrès technologique
alors je vais pas noircir davantage le
tableau vous l'aurez compris et ne pas
non plus tomber dans le cliché du gd
mieux avant mais il faut quand même se
rendre compte qu'on ne peut pas leur
garantir toutes ses propositions parce
qu'on le monde dans lequel nous vivons
et dans lequel nous adultes avons grandi
est en pleine transition et
malheureusement j'ai souvent
l'impression que nous sommes encore
confortablement assis dans notre zone
duty free
une société d'un enfant trop gâté qui
voit toujours le monde comme un immense
terrain de jeu dans lequel nous voulons
continuer à être ses enfants
inconscients et où nous ne sommes
peut-être que des adultes irresponsable
et duty free
ça n'est pas qu'une histoire de détaxe
je serai un autre débat pour ceux pour
qui google 37 et leurs amis ou pour ceux
qui ont passé beaucoup d'heures sur call
of duty duty ça signifie aussi devoir
obligations responsabilité alors oui
nous avons voulu rester libre nous les
adultes nous profiter de tout sans
prendre nos responsabilités face aux
transition actuelle la voilà donc notre
proposition achever la transition vers
un monde où tout est possible tout est à
redéfinir un monde où la technologie
pourrait nous dépasse et où nous ne
serions plus des réfugiés de guerre mais
des réfugiés aussi climatique et
peut-être même sur une autre planète
d'humanité peut encore changer l'avenir
de la terre mais elle peut aussi
s'autodétruire alors posons nous cette
simple question qui aimera mieux
l'humanité qu'elle même si les choix de
cette jeune génération sont dictées par
l'amour de soi et l'amour de l'autre
pour trouver une nouvelle place
si nous acceptons nous qui les
accompagnent ont qui nous renvoie à
notre image alors oui nous pourrons
construire notre avenir et notre futur
ensemble
et croyez moi sont les jeunes qui
accompagneront notre transition
merci
[Applaudissements]